you can make that heading probability
you can see I've got some space here
that I'm deliberately leaving blank
because if I tell you exactly what we're
focusing you on at the outset it's a bit
of a spoiler even though it's something
you actually know so that's what I'm
gonna leave that I'm going to pose you a
question I'm going to give you a
scenario and that scenario hopefully
will give you a justification for having
a look at what we're about to look at so
don't worry about getting any details
down I certainly don't expect you to
replicate the amazing beauty of this
diagram that I'm about to show you but
just take it in with me okay just take
it in with me and then we'll write down
some details so a dinner party twelve
friends go out to dinner okay twelve
friends go out to dinner and all of
those twelve friends nine people eat
lasagna know people in designed you six
people eat apple pie can you tell them
as much time without playing this lesson
and two people ate neither okay so let
me say that again it was a party twelve
people
nine of them a lasagna six eight apple
pie two of them ate neither my question
to you is if I selected one of these
twelve friends at random what's the
probability that they ate lasagna only
okay now as you mat this well what what
immediately strikes you in this in this
question what strikes you about the way
it's been set up and the information in
front of you anything unusual about it
sits here again it's very fair it is
very vague oh I
despite being somewhat vague all the
information that you need is there okay
okay so when you have a look at all of
the things right something doesn't look
like it adds up because if you look at
nine plus six plus two if I'm checking
that right that's 17 isn't it so
something part of the pump doesn't add
up right except for the fact that if you
listen closely to the way I phrased that
question that right at the end there
maybe you worked out what
the key that unlocks this I phrased the
question if I selected one of the twelve
friends they really are 12 at random
what would be the probability that they
ate lasagna only did you catch that word
only what does that imply to you if I
say lasagna only that that implies there
are some people who didn't eat lasagna
only perhaps they ate lasagna and apple
pie so in fact this way that I've shown
you the diagram actually kind of clouds
the fact that there is overlap here
right there's overlap now the tool that
deals with over that is very simple tool
that you've seen many times before the
tool is not hard to use the trick is
when to know when to use that tool and
here is the clue right if you have a
look at a situation that's presented to
you in probability or later on in
permutations and combinations and things
don't seem to add up in the tool that
you need within probability is the Venn
diagram because when I say overlap right
the idea that some of the people eat
lasagna and also add apple pie we
represent that diagrammatically in the
area of a Venn diagram that quite
literally overlaps ok so let's try and
unpack what's going on here maybe now
you want to draw your self sensation and
write down with me the essential details
in this question as we said before there
are 12 friends 12 friends in total we
know that nine people a lasagne six
eight apple pie and two apple pie and
two eight nine oh okay now there are
lots of different kinds of Venn diagrams
that you control but being that you've
got a group of friends and you've got
two categories here that sort of frame
the entire question right
so that means my Venn diagram you know
we usually have circles they don't have
to be circles but we tend to draw
circles how many circles do you think
will represent this
amount of information to categories to
circles and I'm gonna have one circle
for each category like so I will make
one of them the lasagna circle and the
other one the apple pie circle okay now
when you have a look at a finished Venn
diagram it is an exceptionally simple
object there just like a few numbers
here and there and it tells you
everything you need to know it's a very
efficient way of communicating but a
finished Venn diagram kind of disguises
the work that has to go into thinking
about this to create the Venn diagram
all the work is in the creation okay so
some of these numbers here are easier to
put onto the diagram than others I'll
give you an example the first piece of
inflation that I told you or after the
12 friends is that there were nine
people who are in lasagna but I actually
it's not very helpful for me to write
nine do you see why I mean inside this
lasagna circle there are two parts yeah
there's those who ate lasagna but not
apple pie by the way those are kind of
this that's the part I'm interested in
so I'm just gonna label that with a
color there there's those guys and then
there's the people create lasagna but
also ate apple pie do you agree and I
don't know out of that nine I don't know
which ones which at the moment I don't
know if this is their one three five
eight of them I've got no idea okay so I
can't write nine just yet does anyone
want to have a think and help me out
work out what piece of information on
here might be a little easier for me to
put on directly and you take it set
again then either at the end okay so two
people out of these twelve didn't ate
either of the two things that listed
here presumably they either went hungry
or they ate something some non lasagna
non apple pie item on the menu right so
where are these two Niners where are
they gonna go on my diagram yeah
somewhere not in lasagna and not in
apple pie so you know on the outside I
guess you can put it up above or down
below I'm gonna Chuck mine here okay so
these represent
you can call this big box we often call
this the Universal set meaning everyone
in this 12 friend universe okay everyone
we're interested in in this scenario so
that's really good I've got two people
account if I'm just gonna put it there
that's good